it was the biggest turnout of
demonstrators so far after a week of
nationwide protests the demonstration in
algiers started peacefully with
thousands marching in the streets after
Friday prayers they chanted by by
bouteflika and peaceful peaceful many
carried signs with slogans and draped
themselves in national symbols large
crowds also gathered in other cities
according to residents and local media
the protesters are against incumbent
president Abdelaziz Bouteflika seeking a
fifth term in upcoming elections in
April they say he is no longer fit to
lead and are fed up with his iron-fisted
rule it's simple we just want a change
for our country we want a better idea we
the people were here protesting we want
change and freedom later in the day
things got violent police used tear gas
to disperse the crowds and scuffled with
protesters near the presidential palace
an elderly man reportedly died after
being caught in a stampede of protesters
earlier Algerian Prime Minister Ahmed
oyeah gave a chilling warning after
noticing that some demonstrators gave
roses to police officers but we should
recall that in Syria it also began with
roses but flicker who will turn 82 on
Saturday is reportedly in Geneva getting
medical treatment he suffered a stroke
in 2013 and has rarely been seen in
public since authorities say bouteflika
does retain a firm grip on public
affairs his opponents however claim he's
not fit enough to lead the country and
that it is being ruled in his name by
advisers let's get more on the story now
and for that I'm joined in the studio by
Bush Jairam Roone from DW Arabic thanks
for joining us Bashir so do these
protests actually pose a serious threat
to the butiful eco regime well of course
they do there are the the biggest
demonstrations in Algeria since the the
early 1990s and that time the regime
reacted with a massive crackdown which
resulted in a civil war
with over a quarter million of debt and
more than 20,000 missings until today
and as the anger grows these days we can
see member important members of the
regime like Prime Minister Riya trying
to threaten the people via drawing
parallels between the Civil War then and
what's happening today
there are also parallels drawn to the
civil war in Syria so the regime is
frightened there is a serious
possibility that the situation could
develop to a struggle for survival for
the Algerian regime well talking about
those Arab Spring protests of 2011 we
know that back then social media played
a very important role what about this
time around how are the current protests
being organized well I personally I'm
not sure if the social media played the
biggest role than in 12 2011 because
there were also pan Arab news
broadcasters with who played a very big
role but what we can say about Algeria
now is that their evidence there's
evidence that the protests are organized
through Facebook for instance the
initial call to the demonstration is
being reported to have been spread
through Facebook so even so even though
we cannot see we cannot identify the
initial source of it we can say what I
can't say with certainty is the video
shared over YouTube and Facebook via the
power and enthusiasm of the
demonstrations and take them into the
even the smallest towns throughout
everywhere in Algeria all right so it's
clear that these protesters don't want
put a fika to run again but what about
Algeria's opposition like is there
anyone who is a credible figure that
people could unite behind to replace
them mmm well frankly said there is no
real organized opposition inside Algeria
the regime managed in the last twenty
years to destroy every genuine
oppositional party there
also no real civil society so the so
called oppositional parties inside
Algeria are in a patronage they have
patronage links to the regime and enjoy
now public confidence at all I think my
personal opinion is that in the case the
protests are successful and also the
regime we have to put up every
everything new from the ground there in
Algeria all right Bashir I'm Arun from
DW Arabic we really appreciate your
insights thank you
you